les pédiatres monte au front les jeunes
québécois prennent beaucoup trop de
médicaments
c'était il ya presque trois semaines une
sonnette d'alarmé sur le ritalin et
autres psychostimulants consommées en
trop grande quantité
une augmentation continue qui a beaucoup
retenu l'attention
mais les pédiatres signataires de la
lettre avait une crainte on voulait pas
que ça reste un buzz médiatique qu'ils
rêvaient de 4 à comme ça a déjà été le
cas d'ailleurs dans le passé les mêmes
pédiatre appuyés par une vingtaine
d'autres reviennent donc avec des
solutions et le ce temps passé devant
les écrans et dans leur viseur les 65 et
diacres site deux études qui suggère que
l'abus de jeu vidéo peut favoriser
l'apparition de tdh ou aggraver les
troubles
il réclame donc une campagne de
sensibilisation pour inciter à limiter
l'utilisation des jeux vidéo et le temps
d'écran en général on pourrait aussi
envisager poursuivent-t-ils d'interdire
l'utilisation des téléphones cellulaires
et tablettes en milieu scolaire hormis à
des fins éducatives
bravo d'avoir mentionné qu'il y aurait
maintenant de erika sont obligatoires
on pensait déjà que c'était la norme
pour aller plus loin que les récréations
ils voudraient tester les effets de 30 à
45 minutes d'activités sportives
quotidiennes plus de sports - d'écran
mais aussi améliorer l'accès à des
services psychosociaux
cette situation l'homme mérite d'être
entendu en commission parlementaire une
commission qui regrouperait des acteurs
de l'éducation de la santé mais aussi
des parents selon le parti québécois au
s'inquiétait de l'augmentation de la
prescription de psychostimulants 1999
effectivement il y a vingt ans un comité
avait accouché d'un premier rapport
présenté par le ministre de l'éducation
de l'époque c'est bon ou certains enfin
sa note la compagnie d'autres moyens
d'action
mais c'est bon je pense qu'on aurait
réglé hier 1999 leur nez devant le même
problème un problème qui concerne près
de 15 % des jeunes de 13 à 17 ans au
québec une proportion trois fois plus
élevé que dans le reste du canada
mathieu prost radio canada montréal